once again you guys are frying my brain
no of these questions and if so what's
my price tag and if I have a price tag
Amaya roba hello I'm John Cena no
investor being John Cena but now I want
to show the world my knowledge about
robots this is the wire I'll be tested
in four rounds robot ID humans versus
robots
robot render and robots in moonlight run
[Music]
this is this is Wally cuz he wears his
name on his front I believe this is a
robot with claw-like hands and tank
tread for feet also has binoculars for
eyes and it looks like a macro computer
for body ok this this is an alfalfa
based robot some lost its clothing and a
pair of dark briefs and rocket shoes I
would say this is naked rocket foot
Astro Boy was correct astro boy needs to
he's put a shirt on bro he's pretty sure
oh dude this is Robocop I'd buy that for
a dollar so once again this is kind of
what I grew up with Robocop was a cop
who was deceased in the line of duty and
formed into like some hybrid cop and it
was kind of futuristic but like almost
not so I was like in Detroit I believe
was the movie and Robocop is a super
badass and he would like fight for his
right to party and a party or he was
this is Gen 1 Optimus Prime for sure
these are the robots I grew up with this
is my generation back with a simpler
time the robots could do things like
math and that was it transformers more
than meets the eye
transformers who know war is just a lie
Autobots first ascent
mhm oh he's gonna be made it's gonna be
called bumblebee this is our 2d to once
again this is a phat pitch for me
because I was born when Star Wars came
out he could project small boobies
help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my only
hope that was a movie of Princess Leia
projected this this is a very angry
robot with hands of fire just by the
scope of the background it looks like a
an enormous Lee budgeted movie I don't
get out much so
[Music]
flaming mad Cyberman is what that was my
final answer old Ultron okay fair enough
I feel I feel bad about that
oh so this is bender from Futurama I've
washed it enough to laugh along with it
I think it's really cool but I'm not
dedicated enough to know probably anyone
else about bender this is what the
captain of Space Odyssey 2001 would look
like the ship if he indeed were a robot
Marvin the Paranoid Android from
Hitchhiker's Guide that was a I gotta I
gotta go back and watch that one this is
the artificial intelligence from X
Baccano which I thought was an amazing
movie it really comes face to face with
what is living what is not and our fears
of possibly developing artificial
intelligence
forward-thinking but I think it must
watch especially for all those companies
making them a is oh my goodness a
massively famous horror film robot that
I can't remember robot from lost in
space that's why it's iconic it's all
into the next round
human versus robot it's the kid that
sees dead people Bruce Willis is a robot
or something like that it's kids real
Suketu sees dead people
yeah that's right that's the one
Spielberg yeah exactly kids a robot
totally trying to tell you that you like
know it kid sees dead David whatever
this is a robot and it's a recent movie
Blade Runner that's what it's called yes
that's it
these two guys two Nintendo Power gloves
in their hands it's trying to get
through airport security with the masks
on like that that's a threat to the
nation so those are people oh yeah the
music fellas
hmm this is a real person
galactica a robot well you can't win
them all I say this is Iron Man so
underneath there's a human but the human
has a weird heart replacement so this
brings us to weird questions like when
is something really alive because of
like the weird sense of irony see what I
did there it's human because the human
underneath the suit oh man for me to say
human on this one would would be weird
and if it is a human gosh darn do they
need a haircut
so I'm gonna say that's a robot
real-life AI get a good run guys this is
a Handmaid's Tale variant and that's a
real person exactly
handmade still raise your hand mades
tale if you don't watch a lot of Current
TV Arnold Schwarzenegger is iconic role
as the Terminator this is a robot
disguised as a human to travel back in
time to try to kill the leader of the
uprising resistance against a machines
that is a robot because no human being
would be able to keep up the daunting
schedule of robot examination quizzes
would somebody just please plug me in
because I'm feeling kind of drained here
we go round three
robot render here it is its whom I would
be if I would become a transformer that
transforms from a robot into a toilet
it's a robot called the jontron it's a
John and then as you can see it
transforms into John I was given ten
points and five bonus for creativity and
giving Hasbro another franchise going
into round 4 the final round
I have 30 points so I feel like I'm
acing this and if we differ an opinion
you know I I'm not hating on you but
you're wrong so cool fourth round robots
in real life here we go
what this is the Sony AIBO a $3,000
robot dog okay all right stand up don't
lay down I bow
hands up
we were having fun I'm talking about
movies you know I drew I drew a toilet
I'm already a skosh finicky about the AI
you can tell by my comments or max
Makana yeah so for the quiz I have a
total of 40 points and for that I thank
you I'm John Cena scared to death this
has been the wired robot quiz please let
me know how you did so I can get my
sanity back